Speaker 1: aid publicly they have to be
neutral, so please don't say who we are. But
they said in response to us saying, listen,
here's what's going on. They said, quote,
We advocate for free speech. Therefore, we are not
concerned with David's comments. We would prefer
to continue the partnership and stand up to those
who are looking to destroy freedom of speech.
We also have a second advertiser that wrote to
Noah. Noah handles our all of our ads and says,
I've been monitoring the situation. And while
we're seeing some emails both in opposition to
and in support of David, it's nothing too crazy.
No emails from any of our actual customers, though
they all claim to be. And this is as I've said.
The people trying to get us canceled with our
advertisers. They're not my viewers. And they're
also not the customers of any of our advertisers.
This advertiser went on to say. Personally, I'm so
incredibly tired of the outrage economy discourse
that now thrives on social media and those like
Miss Owens, Candace Owens, that promote it,
the mob mentality has fully taken hold. If these
people were even half as mad about the constant
school shootings as they are about a now deleted
tweet, maybe there would be some progress on the
issue. Just like every faux outrage of that, I'm
sure this will all blow over in a few days. Once
there is something new for people to complain
about. Appreciate you putting our ads on hold
for a bit. We told our advertisers we won't run
anything for the rest of this week because we
don't want all of your videos with your ads to
be filled with anti-Semitic comments. Appreciate
putting the ads on hold for a bit. We've been
really happy with our sponsorship of David's
show and look forward to working with him in the
future. That is inspiring to see from advertisers
who see this for what it is. We also saw some
really great videos published by our friends
and colleagues, Kyle Kaminski and Jesse Dallimore.
Kyle put out a video called Candace Owens Attacks
David Pakman, where Kyle brilliantly breaks down
the obviously contrived right wing mob over an
obvious tweet about how thoughts and prayers don't
stop shootings. Jesse Dallimore put out a video
called David Pakman is being attacked by Donald
Trump Jr and other right wing ghouls where he
also espouses total moral and factual clarity
about the situation. But even more important,
we love Jesse and Kyle. But even more important
is all of you look at the response from all of
you. I asked you, please subscribe to the YouTube
channel because imagine the message we would send
to this targeted right wing mob by coming out of
this with a bigger YouTube channel. And you did
more than 5000 w subscribe to the YouTube channel
just yesterday and it's already on fire today.
Thank you. I asked you email our advertisers,
tell them stick with David. That is actual
viewers support you Hundreds of you see feed
me on thousands of emails to advertisers.
Nearly 50 people started new Patreon pledges
at Patria CNN.com slash David Pakman show
another 40 of you signed up for the premium
newsletter via substack. But listen to this. I,
I, I'm a big, strong guy, but I almost have
tears in my eyes as Donald Trump would say,
over 700 new website members in the last 24
hours. We created this coupon code exactly
to track this. The code is cancel. Cancel.
The idea is cancel the counselors cancel,
cancel. And that code works at join Pacman dot
com. As of 9 a.m. this morning, 478 new members
signed up with that code and over 700 new members
in total. A couple of hundred of you didn't even
use the code. You paid full price. And if I look
right now, they're coming in one every 2 minutes.
It is unbelievable. So, listen, the advertiser
losses are significant. I can't will that
away. It's just the reality. But some of
our advertisers see this for what it is.
The new memberships are helping to offset those
losses. And maybe most importantly, those YouTube
subscriber growth numbers are really a signal
that my actual audience, not the people who now
are coming, Oh, I used to love your show, but now
are actual audience gets the whole point of this.
Thoughts and prayers don't stop mass shootings,
whether it's at a Christian school or a secular
school. That's really what this is about. So thank
you. Keep subscribing. Keep the memberships going.
I can't tell you how much I appreciate it. And
come Monday, we'll see where everything stands.
But what a 48 hours. Let's now get back to
the really important stuff that's going on